[موسيقى]
يا مها اين كانت البورما
بالله الواحد الاحد الذي خلق هذا الكون
واضافه الى ايماننا بالله الواحد الاحد
نؤمن ايضا بالموت والبحث بعد الممات وان
الجسد يموت ولكن الروح لا تموت بل تذهب
الى مضيف الله
روحي انسان
عندما تكون حره هي جزء من الحقيقه بينما
تقييد الجسد الانسان الاهواء والنزوات
والنزعات الماديه لكن الروح تكون هادئه
ومطمئنه واكتسبت هذه الروح
تعود الى هذه الدنيا الف مره واحده ولكنها
تتلبس بجسد وشكل اخر والرجل الصالح عندما
تعود روحه سيجد امامه حياه جديده مريحه
وعائله مزدهره وهذا جزاء لعمله الصالحه
اما الشخص السيء عندما تعود روحه الى هذه
الدنيا سيعيش في شقاء وتعاسه ونحن لا نؤمن
بوجود الجنه والنار كما يتم الحديث عنها
ولكننا نؤمن بقيام الساعه ونهايه العالم
وبعد ان تعود روح الانسان الى هذه الدنيا
كما ذكرنا صادقا بما يعادل الف مره ومره
واحده فاذا عملت صالحا في معظم تلك العوده
فان روح الانسان ستكون قريبه من نور الله
ومن الله نفسه واذا كان عمل الانسان سيئا
في معظم تلك العودات فستكون بعيده عن نور
الله